[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
den Sport in der Sendung präsentiert
gleich Norbert Lehmann
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Kinderarmut und ihr Preis eine Studie
waren vor Folgekosten in Milliardenhöhe
reicht die geplante Kinder
Grundsicherung aus
fast
2500 Tote in diesem Jahr in Haiti
eskaliert die Bandengewalt tausende
Menschen flüchten aus der Hauptstadt
und Franken unter Wasser heftige
Unwetter ziehen über die Region
besonders hart trifft es Nürnberg
[Musik]
die Diakonie rechnet heute in einer
Studie vor dass es sich auch rein
wirtschaftlich lohnt mehr gegen
Kinderarmut zu tun was er auf die Mühlen
von Lisa Paus die grüne
Familienministerin streitet seit Monaten
mit Finanzminister Lindner um mehr Geld
für die Kinder Grundsicherung das
belastet zunehmend des Regierungsbündnis
aus Berlin
Erpressung das wirft die FDP der
Familienministerin vor Lisa Paus
blockiere andere Vorhaben ohne ihre
Kinder Grundsicherung überhaupt
durchzurechnen heute der Konter das
Konzept sei fertig und Paust brauche
dafür sicher mehr Geld der Bundeskanzler
hat deutlich gemacht dass die Kinder
Grundsicherung nicht nur sicherstellen
sollen dass alle die Anspruch auf
staatlich Unterstützung haben diese auch
erhalten sondern dass die
Kindergrundsicherung auch
Leistungsverbesserungen enthält die
Kinder Grundsicherung soll Leistungen
wie das Elterngeld und zusatzbeträge
zusammenfassen außerdem den Bezug
vereinfachen die grüne
Familienministerin will auch Milliarden
für weitere Leistungsverbesserungen die
FDP lehnt das ab auch nach dem Auftritt
von Pause heute und die Leistung müssen
einfach und digital abrufbar sein das
ist der zentrale Punkt einfach nur
Leistung auszuweiten wäre mir zu wenig
und bekämpft auch keine Kinderarmut in
Deutschland in Kabinett am Mittwoch
blockierte Pause ein Vorhaben von
Christian Lindner sie brauche vorher
Klarheit über die Kinder Grund
Absicherung der Bundeskanzler konnte den
Eklat nicht abwenden die Opposition
attestiert Führungsschwäche Scholz aber
lobt heute sein Krisenmanagement da habe
ich sehr dafür gesorgt dass es einen
großen Fortschritt gibt und wie ich
schon bei verschiedenen Gelegenheit
gesagt haben wir sind mit 99 Prozent
vielleicht sind es nur 98 je nachdem was
man zählt fertig den Rest schaffen wir
auch noch wie viel Geld genau sie
braucht das sagt Pauls auch heute nicht
ihr Papier dazu seid zwar da aber
vertraulich Nachfragen der Presse war
nicht zugelassen
schon wieder krabbelt sich die Koalition
Theo call in Berlin was ist das
besondere an dieser Auseinandersetzung
also es gibt es offensichtlich besondere
und darunter verborgen gleich noch
mindestens zwei weitere Konflikte an der
Oberfläche ist es ja der sehr
ungewöhnliche Vorgang einer Geiselhaft
also eine Ministerin Frau Pauls hält das
Gesetz eines Kollegen Lindner auf und
will nur zustimmen wenn ihr eigenes
Gesetz durchgeht und das ganze Verfahren
spielt sich dann laut Poltern auf
offener politischer Bühne ab das ist für
eine Regierung die gerade aus den Ferien
zurückkommen zudem mit der kanzleransage
künftig weniger laut zu streiten ein
denkbar schlechter Neustart
dreierbeziehungen sind ja bekanntermaßen
im Leben schwierig und die Politik macht
da offensichtlich keine Ausnahme und
zusätzlich öffnen sich jetzt weitere
Risse sowohl innerhalb der Grünen denn
habe ich und der realoflügel hatten
Lindner schon Zustimmung signalisiert
und stehen jetzt machtloser da als
vorher und auch der Kanzler dem eine
Mehrheit der Menschen Führungsschwäche
bescheinigt bekommt zunehmend gegen wenn
das der eigenen Partei die mehr will als
immer nur leise vermitteln die Listen
jedenfalls mit in den kommenden
Konflikten für die zweite Halbzeit der
Ampel die sind längst geschrieben die
Einschätzung von Theo Koll aus Berlin
vielen Dank
was ist den Start kostet wenn er nicht
in seine Kinder investiert zeigt wie
erwähnt eine Studie des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung im
Auftrag der Diakonie danach liegen die
Folgekosten von Kinderarmut bei bis zu
120 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr der Grund
von Armut betroffene Kinder haben
schlechtere Berufsperspektiven sie haben
ein höheres Risiko krank oder arbeitslos
zu werden und sie sind stärker abhängig
von staatlichen Leistungen Martin Niesen
berichtet
ein Urlaubstag für die die sich keinen
Urlaub leisten können in der Arche in
Hamburg-Harburg haben sie einen Parcours
mit Geschicklichkeitsspielen aufgebaut
mehr als 50 Kinder sind in die
Tagesstätte des Kinder- und Jugendwerks
gekommen auch beim kostenlosen
Mittagessen bleibt kein Platz leer ganz
wichtig ist heute die
Lebensmittelausgabe die Lebensmittel
sind zu teuer geworden man spart an
Bildung das ist eigentlich das ganz
schlimme Kinderarmut und die Folgen hat
das Deutsche Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung nun im Auftrag der
Diakonie untersucht Ergebnis alle bisher
gemachten Vorschläge zur
Kindergrundsicherung reichen nicht
notwendig während mindestens 20
Milliarden Euro das ist nur ein
Bruchteil der Summe die Staat und
Steuerzahler heute schon schultern
müssen weil wir Kinderarmut eben nicht
energisch bekämpfen sondern uns damit
abfinden dass sie sich verfestigt wir
nehmen also liebe die enorm vollgekosten
in Kauf höre Belastungen für Gesundheit
und Sozialsysteme sowie geringere
Wirtschaft Aktivität und Produktivität
Kosten demnach schon jetzt bis zu 120
Milliarden Euro im Jahr das zweite was
wichtig ist betonen ist es auch für die
Gesellschaft als Ganzes denn Nutzen
einer effektiven Kindergrundsicherung
und von Investitionen in Menschen ein
enorm Nutzen hat und das gilt kaum mehr
als heute in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangels das Potenzial von
Kindern stärker fördern und nutzen das
fordern sie auch in der Arche
die wir in Deutschland haben wir müssen
uns um unsere Kinder kümmern dann werden
sie es um später tausendfach
zurückzahlen indem sie arbeiten und
Steuern bezahlen an den Kindern geht der
politische Zwist in dess vorbei mit bei
den Spielen gewonnenen Chips können Sie
Stifte Bücher oder Spiele kaufen Dinge
die sie sich sonst nicht leisten können
wir haben es gehört seit dieser Woche
ist die Bundesregierung aus der
Sommerpause zurück und es gab direkt
neuen Knatsch das kommt nicht gut an
Matthias zorndorf ist hier mit dem neuen
Politbarometer die schneidet guten Abend
wie schneidet die Regierung da ab die
meisten haben den Eindruck es geht nicht
so recht voran und entsprechend negativ
ist die Bewertung dass die
Bundesregierung ihre Arbeit gut macht
finden 37 Prozent 58 Prozent aber sagen
sie macht es schlecht eine CDU
csu-regierung würde es auch nicht besser
machen klappt eine Mehrheit von 52
Prozent 17 Prozent glauben sogar es
würde schlechter
die schlechte Bewertung betrifft nicht
nur Parteien sondern auch Personen würde
sich CDU-Chef Merz als Kanzler eignen
69 Prozent sagen Nein und auch eine
Mehrheit von 50 Prozent der
Unionsanhänger glaubt nicht das März
Kanzler kann aber auch der amtierende
Kanzler Olaf Scholz verliert deutlich an
Zustimmung was ist mit der
Wirtschaftslage gibt es da mehr
Zustimmung
Pessimismus als Zuversicht das ist mit
der deutschen Wirtschaft bergauf geht
erwarten gerade mal sechs Prozent der
Befragten 61 Prozent glauben es geht
eher abwärts 31 Prozent gehen davon aus
dass es so bleibt wie es ist
schauen wir nach aufs Kräfteverhältnis
der Parteien wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD auf 19
Prozent plus 2
cdu/csu 26 % minus 1 grüne 15 - 1 FDP 7
AFD 20 linke 5% + 1 die Ampel hätte
damit keine Mehrheit reichen würde es
für cdu/csu entweder mit Grünen und FDP
oder mit SPD und FDP immer wieder
interessant vielen Dank Matthias das
gesamte Politbarometer gibt es im heute
journal um 22 Uhr und schon jetzt online
in unserer App finden Sie auch welche
Politiker in der Bewertung vorliegen und
wie das Gesetz zur cannabis-freigabe
gesehen wird
schauen wir nach Österreich dort ist der
frühere Bundeskanzler kurz wegen
Falschaussage angeklagt worden kurz soll
bei der Besetzung des chefpostens einer
staatlichen Gesellschaft zugunsten
seines vertrauten Thomas Schmidt in der
interveniert haben später habe er seine
Einflussnahme vor einem
Parlamentsausschuss aber
heruntergespielt kurz drohen bis zu drei
Jahre Haft Prozessbeginn ist Mitte
Oktober
seit Monaten drängt die Ukraine auf die
Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen aus dem
Westen jetzt kommt Bewegung in die Sache
die USA haben grünes Licht gegeben somit
können die Niederlande und Dänemark wie
angekündigt F16 Jets liefern dem musste
Washington zustimmen da es sich um ein
Waffensystem aus den USA handelt
ukrainische Piloten sollen jetzt an der
F16 ausgebildet werden damit sie Anfang
nächsten Jahres einsatzfähig sind
es ist ein Treffen dass die US-Regierung
jetzt schon als historisch bezeichnet
US-Präsident beiden empfängt Japans
Regierungschef kishida und den
südkoreanischen Präsidenten nun zu einem
Gipfel in Camp David bei dem Treffen auf
dem Land Sitz des US-Präsidenten wollen
sich die drei Länder enger in
Sicherheitsfragen abstimmen angesichts
zunehmender Spannungen im Asien
Pazifikraum es handelt sich um das erste
eigenständige Gipfeltreffen zwischen den
USA Japan und Südkorea
Wissen in Washington was haben die USA
davor
alle drei Anführer haben das hier vorhin
als historisch bezeichnet ich glaube das
passt hier entsteht ein neues
Dreierbündnis eine Allianz vergleichbar
mit der NATO ohne eine gegenseitige
Beistandsverpflichtung aber mit allem
darunter zum Beispiel eine enge
militärische und geheimdienstliche
Zusammenarbeit eine trilaterale Hotline
eine Verpflichtung zur gegenseitigen
engen Abstimmung im Konfliktfall und das
ganze wird so institutionalisiert das
ist auch nicht einfach wieder
zurückgedreht werden kann wenn sich die
politischen Verhältnisse in einem der
Länder verändern und in einem nächsten
Schritt wäre vorstellbar das Japan und
Südkorea ihre Raketenabwehrsysteme
miteinander verbinden das ist besonders
bemerkenswert angesichts der
Verwerfungen die ist ja aber viele
Jahrzehnte zwischen Südkorea und der
ehemaligen Besatzungsmacht Japan aus
historischen Gründen gegeben hat man
will offenbar ein gemeinsames starkes
militärisches und politisches Signal an
China senden wenn es die
Sicherheitsinteressen eines der
Bündnispartner beeinträchtigt im
inopazifik muss es mit Reaktionen von
allen dreien rechnen danke schön nach
Washington emativ wissen
es gibt solche und solche Jahrestage dem
Iran steht ein brisanter bevor am 16
September vergangenen Jahres starb
Mascha Amini in Haft festgenommen weil
sie angeblich gegen die islamische
Kleiderordnung verstoßen hatte es
folgten Proteste und zumindest in
Teheran zeigten sich immer mehr Frauen
demonstrativ mit offenem Haar dagegen
will das Regime jetzt hart durchgreifen
Alexander Pool berichtet
die große Mutter befindet sich im Herzen
terrath das wöchentliche Freitagsgebet
die meisten hier wünschen sich scharfere
kopftuchgesetze
das Kopftuch ist eine Angelegenheit
Gottes darüber sollten keine Menschen
entscheiden
irans-garden dieses Versprechen ab
ich versichere Ihnen das Abnehmen des
Kopftuchs wird definitiv ein Ende haben
machen sie sich da keine Sorgen ich
das Regime fürchtet ähnliche Aufstände
wie nach dem Tod von Macho armini die
nach ihrer Festnahme in Polizei
Gewahrsam starb und so berät das
Parlament jetzt härtere Strafen gegen
Frauen die kein Kopftuch tragen das
Strafmaß wird von Fall zu Fall
unterschiedlich sein aber es wird Frauen
in allen Lebenslagen betreffen
ob Frauen ohne Kopftuch die U-Bahn
nutzen oder ins Kino gehen dürfen wird
bisher von Fall zu Fall entschieden
durch die neuen Gesetze könnte das
grundsätzlich verboten werden
die Strafen die für Frauen ohne Kopftuch
diskutiert werden sind weit härter als
etwa für Betrug oder Drogenhandel
es gibt viele Frauen und Männer die sich
gegen die geplanten Gesetze aussprechen
es kommt nicht akzeptieren weil es das
Gesetz einer Minderheit ist sie können
das Gesetz verabschieden aber für uns
gibt es keinen Weg zurück
bis die neuen Regeln tatsächlich in
Kraft treten könnten aber mehrere Monate
vergehen
nach Haiti viele Einwohner dort leben in
bittere Armut und leiden Hunger jetzt
spitzt sich ein weiteres Problem zu die
Bandenkriminalität Gangs sollen
mittlerweile bis zu drei Viertel der
Hauptstadt Porto Prince unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht haben sie
terrorisieren die Einwohner
vergewaltigen und morden fast 2500 tote
zählte die UN seit Jahresbeginn tausende
sind auf der Flucht David sauer
berichtet
was die Gänge Gewalt anrichtet zeigt
sich auf den Straßen von Haiti gerade
täglich seit mehr als zwei Jahren halten
kriminelle Banden das Land im Griff sie
entführen vergewaltigen üben
Selbstjustiz auf den Straßen gilt das
rechte stärkeren gegen diese Herrschaft
des Verbrechens gibt es immer wieder
Proteste das Volk verlangt Schutz viele
verlassen ihre Häuser und wenn sich die
Lage verschlimmert werden wir
unglücklichen die Opfer sein wir haben
niemanden wir kämpfen allein
diese Unzufriedenheit tragen Sie auf die
Straßen gegen den Start der keine
Autorität mehr hat die Polizei ist
unterbesetzt und überfordert in dieses
Vakuum sind mit macht die Gangs gestoßen
die Banden zur entwaffen und endlich
Frieden herzustellen das fordert
UN-Generalsekretär gotisch mit einem
internationalen Einsatz
rufe die internationale Gemeinschaft auf
dem von mir gewünschten Beschluss des
UN-Sicherheitsrates endlich Folge zu
leisten jetzt ist nicht die Zeit Haiti
zu vergessen
die Kontrolle über die Viertel
aufzugeben daran denken die Gangs gar
nicht einer der einflussreichsten
Bandenchefs droht in drastischen Worten
mit noch mehr Gewalt
wenn sie in die Ghettos und Gemeinden
kommen und anfangen zu schießen und zu
Wasser kreieren werden wir halt Jana uns
erheben und bis zum letzten Blutstropfen
kämpfen
die Versorgungslage in Haiti ist
verheerend es fehlt am nötigsten Medizin
Wasser Nahrungsmittel die Hälfte der elf
Millionen Bewohner hungert und viele
sind auf der Flucht
die gute Nachricht vom Deutschen
Wetterdienst heute die schweren
gewitterlagen sind erstmal vorbei
gestern aber traf es den Süden und Osten
noch mal heftig besonders schlimm war es
in Franken Petra Neubauer
es sind gewaltige Regenmengen die da
gestern auf die Stadt niederprasseln und
unter Führungen binnen weniger Minuten
volllaufen lassen jetzt nur raus aus dem
Auto aus eigener Kraft oder mithilfe
anderer die Rettungskräfte kontrollieren
jedes Fahrzeug groß ist die Sorge es
könnte noch jemand drin sein
auch die Straßenbahn muss vor den
Wassermassen kapitulieren fast einen
Meter 80 hoch steht das Wasser hier für
ein paar Stunden fällt der Strom aus
etwas weiter südwestlich knicken heftige
Windböen Bäume um hinterlassen ein Bild
der Verwüstung 12 Autos werden getroffen
mehrere Insassen verletzt
waren die letzten zwei Stunden beiseite
geräumt hat und welchen Durchmesser die
hatten also das hat ganz anders ausgehen
können heute das Unwetter über Franken
ist abgezogen die Spuren aber sind auch
am Tag danach unübersehbar
Regenmassen in Deutschland enorme Hitze
und Trockenheit auf den Kanaren und als
Folge verheerende Waldbrände auf
Teneriffa betroffen ist vor allem der
Norden der beliebten Urlaubsinsel
inzwischen wurde eine Fläche von rund
5000 Fußballfeldern zerstört tausende
Menschen mussten in Sicherheit gebracht
werden die Feuerwehr ist mit
Löschflugzeugen im Einsatz eine Ahrend
kilometerweit bahnen sich die Flammen
durch den Nationalpark das bergige
Areale im Norden der Insel ist mitunter
schwer zugänglich aus der Luft versuchen
Soldaten den Brand einzudämmen der
bereits eine Fläche von fast 4000 Hektar
zerstört hat was oder wer den Brand
entfacht hat ist nicht bekannt seit
Mitte der Woche mussten mehrere tausend
Menschen ihre Häuser verlassen um sich
vor dem beißenden Rauch zu schützen
tragen sie Masken
es ist wirklich ein schreckliches Feuer
die Sicherheit der Menschen das ist
jetzt das wichtigste
mit Sorge beobachten Sie die lodernden
Flammen in den umliegenden Wäldern
hoffen dass ihre Dörfer verschont
bleiben tatsächlich scheint sich die
Lage inzwischen etwas zu beruhigen die
Regionalregierung verkündet das Feuer
breite sich langsamer aus
wir können sagen dass ich das Feuer mehr
und mehr wie ein normaler Brand verhält
also anders als in den zwei Tagen zuvor
an denen es einen Klima schaffte dass
sich die Flammen immer selbst entfachten
es soll sich um einen der schwersten
Brände seit 40 Jahren handeln trockener
Waldboden hohe Temperaturen und starke
Winde machten den Einsatzkräften zu
schaffen der Zugang zum Wandergebiete
rund um den vulkante bleibt erst einmal
gesperrt darüber hinaus soll es laut
Behörden jedoch keine Einschränkungen
für Urlauber geben
auch auf anderen Kontinenten brennt es
Kanada erlebt die schlimmste
Waldbrandsaison seiner Geschichte im
Nordwesten des Landes sind tausende
Menschen auf der Flucht vor den Flammen
die Evakuierung der Stadt yellow knife
mit ihrem 20.000 Bürgern dauert an und
im Südwesten bedroht ein verheerender
Brand die Stadt killowna dort wurde der
Notstand ausgerufen auch hier sind die
Flammen nur noch wenige Kilometer von
der Stadt entfernt
jetzt zum Sport da ist es wieder soweit
die Fußball-Bundesliga startet neuer
heute abend Werder gegen Bayern
eine Klatsche einstecken müssen Werder
mit dem Pokal aus gegen Drittligist
Viktoria Köln ja und München mit dem
bitteren 0:3 im Supercup gegen Leipzig
da müssen Bayern Trainer Tuchel und
Hoffnungsträger kennen wohl heute abend
liefern
immerhin ist der 100 Millionen Mann der
teuerste Einkauf der 60-Jährigen
Bundesliga Geschichte er hat jetzt über
den Jahrzehnt bewiesen dass er mit Druck
umgehen kann deshalb mache ich mir zum
Harry gar keine Gedanken eher um seine
instabile Abwehr die beim 0:3 im
Supercup von Leipzig vernascht wurde der
Koreaner Kim auch ein 50 Millionen
Einkauf soll mehr Stabilität bringen mit
Bremen wartet im Weserstadion ein
vermeintlich schlagbarer Gegner das ist
natürlich auch wichtig dass man nicht
nur wie das Kaninchen vor der Schlange
verteidigt Mut und Leidenschaft sind
gefragt
die deutschen Volleyballerinnen sind mit
einem souveränen Sieg in die Heim-EM
gestartet das Team besiegte gestern
Abend in Düsseldorf Griechenland mit 3:0
einziger Wermutstropfen die Verletzung
von Deutschlands bester
angriffsspielerin Hanna Ortmann weitere
Turnierteilnahme ungewiss
ja noch eine Heime in hat begonnen die
im Hockey in Mönchengladbach die
deutschen Frauen bei der letzten EM
zweite treten gleich gegen Schottland an
und auch die Männer gehören zu den
Favoriten
erst im Januar wurden sie überraschend
Weltmeister in Indien mit
beeindruckender Nervenstärke und
Kampfkraft daher sehen sich die
Deutschen Hockey Männer auch bei der
Heim EM in Mönchengladbach auf Titel
kurz die Frauen eher Außenseiterinnen
sie wollen einfach ihr bestes Hockey
zeigen ich glaube die Vorfreude steigt
jetzt so langsam wir sind jetzt hier
auch in Mönchengladbach auf dem Platz
denke ich angekommen hatten die letzten
Trainingseinheiten und auch
Trainingsspiele hier und jetzt langsam
ist so das Gefühl glaube ich es könnte
jetzt losgehen es ist die erste Heim em
seit 12 Jahren und das größte
Hockeystadion Europas fast ausverkauft
und das erste Spiel der Männer morgen
Abend gegen Wales live zu sehen bei uns
in der ZDF Mediathek 1830 Dankeschön
morgen wird es richtig heiß
hitzewarnungen gibt es für fast ganz
Deutschland Details hat gleich aus den
terli das heute journal um 10 mit Anne
gallinek das gesamte heute Team wünscht
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende tschüss bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter den nächsten Tagen
bleibt es heiß es liegt hauptsächlich an
dieser südwestlichen Strömung aber
morgen erreicht uns noch eine Kaltfront
und im Nordwesten gibt es dann einige
Schauer und auch einzelne kräftigere
Gewitter und dazu doch recht viele
Wolken in der Nacht ist es größtenteils
trocken teilweise bildet sich Nebel ganz
im Norden sind einige Schauer dabei und
am angenehmsten in dieser kommende Nacht
im Südosten bei 14 bis 15 Grad angenehm
kühl im Vergleich zum besten 20 bis 22
Grad per Definition eine tropische Nacht
und in den Großstädten kühlt es kaum ab
morgen dann im Nordwesten viele Wolken
dann Schauer und auch einzelne kräftige
Gewitter sonst viel Sonnenschein und
eine hohe bis teils extreme
Hitzebelastung im Südwesten 35 Grad
angenehmer ganz im Nordwesten in Nordsee
bei 26 Grad ja die Hitze bleibt 35 Grad
in den nächsten Tagen immer wieder dabei
und einzelne kräftige Schauer und
Gewitter ja und dann auch am Dienstag
Gewitter vor allem im Westen und damit
ein schöner Abend